two years ago we hit rock bottom but
still we rise roses from the concrete we
blossom
I loved ones gone but never forgotten
the fight for justice continues in this
memorial service 72 seconds of silence
one for each victim of the Grenfell fire
two years have passed but the emotion is
still raw as names of those who died
were read aloud and remembered
Jeremiah Dean zeinab Dean vincent regina
fatima afro sahabi a [ __ ] a mayor
- chu ammidon bereaved relatives
survivors and community leaders came to
show respect and solidarity but it was
not only a day for remembrance there was
frustration - the lack of progress and
change Corinne mursili lost his uncle in
the fire and now campaigns with Grenfell
United we're demanding change so we want
the government to start listening to
things that they have heard before Brent
felt these are concerns that have been
made to the government before grandfa
even happened in terms of Building
Regulations you know government
ministers knew that there were issues
not only surrounding the cladding
dangerous materials that were being put
inside the buildings but also buildings
I didn't have sprinklers you know
buildings that the fire doors went fit
for purpose it just didn't work at all
this urgent call for action shared by
firefighters who've warned there could
be another catastrophic loss of life
unless more buildings are made safe
there are a lot of people still living
at risk in high-rise tower blocks over
300 tower blocks around the country
thousands and thousands of people living
at risk in these tower blocks the
government have made empty promises
nothing has happened the risk is still
there and that you would have expected a
government in this time in this day and
age to fulfill their promises and to
made safe dwellings for families in the
21st century like the 14th day of every
month since the grenfell fire a silent
walk
thousands marched through the streets
with bereaved relatives and survivors
joined by residents and political
figures including Labour's Jeremy Corbyn
this an opportunity to stand together
and unite this is not only about paying
tribute with 72 people who died this is
also about coming together and showing
strength demonstrating to the wider
public the people here are still
fighting and demanding change with
delays to the public inquiry and no
criminal charges for a few years at
least justice may be a way off with the
people of Grenfell are standing strong
they say they won't give up the fight
until people are safe in their homes so
a tragedy like grenfell can never happen
again
Charlotte Lomas Sky News